.
AND SEXISM AND NOT STUFF THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO THINK ABOUT THE
AMERICAN FLAG SYMBOLIZING.
>> I A SYMBOL OF HURT.
I'M AFRICAN-AMERICAN.
MY FAMILY REALLY BUILT THIS
COUNTRY UP.
>> IS CONTROVERSIAL.
>> Greg: WOW, 52 SECONDS.
432 LIKES.
I COULD FEEL MY BRAIN DRAINING.
I FEEL SO DUMB.
I FINALLY UNDERSTAND THE APPEAL
OF SETH ROGEN.
THE STUDENTS CHOOSE TO FOCUS ON
THE FLAWED PAST OF A COUNTRY
THAT NOW HAS UNIVERSAL SUFFRAGE,
EQUAL PROTECTION UNDER THE LAW
AND OF COURSE THE "GUTFELD!"
SHOW BUT THE FLAG IS PROBABLY
JUST A PIECE OF CLOTH.
>> DO YOU THINK IT REPRESENTS
FREEDOM?
>> NO, I DON'T.
>> I DON'T IT'S AS FREE AS
PEOPLE THINK IT IS.
I THINK IT'S A PIECE OF CLOTH AT
THE END OF THE DAY.
>> FOR ME, NO.
I DON'T SEE MYSELF REPRESENTED
SO I WOULD NOT SAY IT REPRESENTS
FREEDOM TO ME.
>> IT ONCE DID BUT HONESTLY
RECENTLY I'M NOT TOO SURE
ANYMORE.
WITH EVERYTHING GOING ON, I
DON'T KNOW.
I THINK WE ONCE WERE FREE BUT
NOW THERE'S NEW LAWS AND NEW
THINGS COMING ABOUT, THAT I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S TRUE
ANYMORE.
>> Greg: YEAH, LIKE, TOTALLY.
IT'S LIKE WE LIVE IN A PRISON
STATE.
IT'S LIKE
"SHAWSHANK REDEMPTION."
I GET IT, YOU SEE CUBAN
PROTESTERS CHERISHING SOMETHING
YOU HATE AND IT MUST BE HARD TO
FATHOM.
WHY ARE THEY DOING THAT AND WHY
ARE THEY DISAPPEARING?
>> WHY DO YOU THINK THEY ARE
FLYING THE AMERICAN FLAG IN
THESE DIFFERENT NATIONS?
>> HMM.
WE DON'T REPRESENT A SOCIALIST
GOVERNMENT SO I DON'T KNOW THEY
WOULD WAVE A FLAG.
I'M NOT SURE.
>> DO YOU THINK THEY ARE WAVING
IT BECAUSE IT'S A SYMBOL OF
FREEDOM AND DEMOCRACY?
>> YEAH, THAT COULD BE.
>> WHY DO YOU THINK THESE PEOPLE
ARE WAVING AMERICAN FLAGS
OVERSEAS?
>> UM, THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
>> Greg: WHY WOULD A CUBAN
FLYING AMERICAN FLAG OF IT'S NOT
THERE FLAG?
PERHAPS A DESIRE TO HAVE THE
SAME RIGHTS WE DO.
TO VOTE, PROTEST, SPONGE OFF MOM
AND DAD WHILE YOU GET HIGH
BEFORE NOON.
I GUESS THE FLAG ISN'T A PERFECT
IMAGE OF EQUALITY AND
OPPORTUNITY.
MAYBE THEY SHOULD TRY TO FLY
DIFFERENT FLAG.
>> LOOKING AT THESE PROTESTS AND
THE AMERICAN FLAGS, DO YOU THINK
THERE'S ANOTHER FLAG THAT THEY
SHOULD BE FLYING INSTEAD A BEACH
REPRESENT MORE FREEDOM OR MORE
DEMOCRACY?
WHAT OTHER COUNTRY SHOULD THEY
BE LOOKING TOWARDS?
>> MAY BE SWEDEN.
[LAUGHS]
SOME EUROPEAN COUNTRIES I THINK
ARE DOING BETTER AT EQUALITY.
>> I WOULD SAY IF THEY ARE
TRYING TO SYMBOLIZE EQUITY, I
WOULD SAY EITHER FRANCE OR
SWITZERLAND.
>> WHY DOES IT HAVE TO BE A
NATIONAL FLAG?
>> WE COULD BE FLYING THE
QUALITY FLAG.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT HAS TO BE
NATIONALISTIC.
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD PUT ANY
COUNTRY ON A PEDESTAL.
>> WHAT'S THE COUNTRY WHERE,
LIKE, THERE'S NOT EVEN A PRISON
SYSTEM?
HAVE A LOW CRIME RATE.
WHAT IS THAT COUNTRY?
>> Greg: THERE'S A COUNTRY
THAT DOESN'T HAVE A PRISON
SYSTEM?
SIGN ME UP.
I KNOW OUR LIBERAL RUN CITIES NO
LONGER HAVE A PRISON SYSTEM.
THEY JUST TOSS THE THUGS BACK ON
THE STREET.
BUT I GUESS CANADA IS BETTER,
YEAH, CANADA.
THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE
ELECTRICITY.
BUT AGAIN, HOW CAN STUDENTS MAKE
ANY SENSE FROM OUR OWN MEDIA AND
POLITICIANS ARE BLAMING THE
WORLD FOR AMERICA'S PROBLEMS.
>> COVID, ON TOP OF THE TRUMP
SANCTIONS, CRATERED THEIR
ECONOMY.
SHOULD WE FIND WAYS TO DO MORE
FOR THE CUBAN PEOPLE AND FOR
RELAXING SOME OF THE TRUMP
RESTRICTIONS ON REMITTANCES?
>> Greg: SO WE SHOULD EASE THE
POLICY THAT MIGHT LEAD TO AN END
TO A DICTATORSHIP.
HOW DID SHE FIND HER WAY TO WORK
EVERY MORNING?
I ASK THAT KNOWING THAT SHE
WORKS FROM HOME.
OF COURSE AOC ALSO BLAMES THE
U.S. FOR THE CUBAN CRISIS AND
WHY SHOULDN'T SHE?
THAT'S HER BRAND.
SHE EXCELLENTLY SPILLED A GLASS
OF WINE, HAS A CAVITY OR CAN'T
FIND HER BELT THE MORNING SHE
BLAMES U.S. POLICY.
SHE BLAMES AMERICA'S PAST AND
IGNORES COMMUNISM'S PRESENT.
SHE IS LIKE THE NIKE OF
CONGRESS.
SHOULD WE WORRY WHEN COLLEGE
STUDENTS FAIL TO SEE HOW OUR
COUNTRY AND SPARE SOME OF THE
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD WHO
AREN'T AS LUCKY AS THE STUDENTS.
LET'S ASK THE ANGRY WHITE MALE.
[METAL MUSIC]
♪ ♪
>> ♪♪ YOU'RE A GRAND OLD FLAG ♪
♪ YOU'RE THE EMBLEM OF THE LAND
I LOVE, HOME OF THE FREE AND THE
BRAVE ♪♪
>> Greg: HOW DID HE NOT GET
MURDERED?
I WOULD SUPPOSE IT'S EASY TO
POKE FUN AT PEOPLE WHO'VE TAKEN
OUR FLAG FOR RENTED.
THEY ARE YOUNG, DUMB, AND FULL
OF TERROR.
THAT'S THE REAL TRUTH.
IT'S NOT STUPIDITY.
IT'S FEAR.
THEY KNOW WHAT HAPPENS IF THEY
SEE SOMETHING COUNTER TO THE
APPROVED ANTI-AMERICAN MESSAGE.
YOU CAN LABEL, SENSOR, AND
CANCEL THEM AT THEIR MOST
VULNERABLE.
IT'S THE PERFECT TOOL FOR
INDOCTRINATION.
ASKING ABOUT THE FLAG I GUESS
YOU COULD SAY IT'S LIKE SHOOTING
FISH IN A BARREL EXCEPT HERE THE
FISH WOULD SAY IT'S PREFERABLE
THEN TO LIVING IN AMERICA.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS!
SHE'S GOT MORE YOUTUBE VIEWS
THAN CATS FALLING OFF COUCHES.
HOST OF "THE LAUREN CHEN SHOW"
ON YOUTUBE, LAUREN CHEN.
HE'S THROWN MORE HANDCUFFED MEN
INTO THE BACKSEAT THAN MADONNA.
AUTHOR OF "BREAKING BLUE,"
SEAN C. LARKIN.
HE'S SO CATHOLIC,
HE BRUSHES HIS TEETH
WITH HOLY WATER.
HOST OF "THE QUIZ SHOW"
ON FOX NATION, TOM SHILLUE.
ANGRY WHITE MALE.
AND SHE'S BEEN RESUSCITATED
MORE TIMES THAN
A RED CROSS MANNEQUIN.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
KAT TIMPF.
WELCOME BACK TO THE SHOW,
LAUREN.
>> Lauren: GREAT TO BE HERE.
>> Greg: IS IT REALLY GREAT?
I WAS JOKING ABOUT CANADA.
YOU DO HAVE ELECTRICITY.
>> Lauren: FOR NOW.
WE'LL SEE HOW THINGS GO.
AMERICA, FREEDOM IN THE AIR AND
GROWTH HORMONES IN THE BEEF.
>> Sean: WE HAVE ELECTRICITY,
INTERNET AND PLUMBING IN
OKLAHOMA.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK YOU
SHOULD TELL PEOPLE THAT.
THEY WILL START MOVING THERE.
YOU DON'T WANT MORE PEOPLE
THERE.
YOU WANT LESS PEOPLE THERE.
FEWER?
YOU DO LOOK LIKE A TEACHER?
LAUREN, IS IT TOO EASY TO DO
THESE KINDS OF MAN ON THE STREET
STUFF WITH STUDENTS?
OR IS IT JUST TO POINT OUT HOW
ENDEMIC THEIR BRAINWASHING IS?
>> Lauren: I HAVE HAD PEOPLE
SAY THIS ISN'T GOING TO BE
CHANGING ANY PEOPLE'S MINDS.
IT'S NOT MEANT TO CHANGE
STUDENTS MINDS.
THE IMPORTANT THING TO REMEMBER
IS THE STUDENTS ARE NOT
REPRESENTATIVE OF EVERYBODY.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE
REST OF THE WORLD REALLY
UNDERSTANDS HOW UNIVERSITY
STUDENTS ARE REALLY NOT
EVERYTHING THEY ARE CRACKED UP
TO BE.
AT LEAST IN TERMS OF
UNDERSTANDING SOCIO-ECONOMIC OR
GEOPOLITICAL ISSUES.
IT'S LIKE THAT ONE GIRL WEARS --
BUSHY ACCIDENTALLY LIBERTARIAN?
DOES SHE WANT MORE FREEDOM?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
I DON'T THINK SHE DOES EITHER.
>> Greg: I FEEL LIKE MAYBE WE
ARE BEING TO COOL.
TRYING TO IMAGINE YOU AS THEIR
AGE.
CAN YOU REMEMBER THAT?
>> Sean: I WAS DRIVING A BEER
TRUCK AND PARTYING A LOT.
>> Greg: HOW WOULD YOU HAVE
ANSWERED?
HOW WOULD YOU HAVE ANSWERED?
WOULD YOU HAVE BEEN BETTER OR
WORSE?
WHAT WOULD YOU HAVE SAID?
>> Sean: I THINK I MENTIONED
BEFORE MY FATHER WAS IN THE
MILITARY 32 YEARS.
MY MOM WAS ACTIVE DUTY FOR 20.
I WAS RAISED ON MILITARY BASES
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
STILL TO THIS DAY HAVING THAT
FLAG ON, MY SHOULDER AS A POLICE
OFFICER IS ALWAYS A BIG DEAL.
DEFINITELY WHAT ABOUT A BETTER
ANSWER.
>> Greg: WHAT WOULD YOU HAVE
SAID?
>> Sean: THE AMERICAN FLAG, IT
REPRESENTS EXACTLY THAT.
FREEDOM.
THAT'S WHY THE PEOPLE IN CUBA
HOP ON RAFTS TO TRY TO GET HERE.
NO ONE ON THE U.S. IS HOPPING ON
RAFTS TO GET TO CUBA.
BASEBALL PLAYERS THAT COME TO
THE U.S. FOR TOURNAMENTS AND
THINGS, THEY ASKED TO STAY HERE.
THEY DON'T WANT TO GO BACK.
OPPORTUNITY IS ABSOLUTELY.
>> Greg: BRINGING UP
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
THEY HAVE NOT SAID ANYTHING
ABOUT THIS.
DARN PRO SPORTS SUPPOSED TO BE
POLITICAL.
SO MANY CUBAN BASEBALL PLAYERS
AND THEY HAVEN'T SAID ANYTHING.
TOM, HOW ARE YOU?
>> Tom: GREAT.
>> Greg: I CAN TELL.
YOU LOOK VERY, YOU LOOK VERY
TOM SHILLUE, VERY WHITE, VERY
ANGRY AND VERY MALE.
>> Tom: I CAN'T HELP IT.
I CAN'T HELP IT.
>> Greg: I WISH YOU COULD.
>> Tom: I HAVEN'T BEEN ON THE
COLLEGE CAMPUS SINCE I WAS IN
COLLEGE.
BUT WHEN I WAS IN COLLEGE, THERE
WAS A FEW PEOPLE LIKE THIS,
THERE WAS ONE TABLE OF
COMMUNISTS IN THE LUNCHROOM AND
YOU KNOW ABOUT THEM.
THEY TALKED ABOUT THIS AND THEY
HELD ANTI-FOURTH OF JULY
CELEBRATION SOME THINGS.
NOW IT'S THE MAJORITY OF
STUDENTS.
I WILL HAVE SYMPATHY FOR THEM
BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN
BRAINWASHED SINCE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL.
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT CRITICAL RACE
THEORY AND THE INDOCTRINATION
THAT'S GOING ON TODAY.
THE THING IS IT'S REALLY BEEN
GOING ON FOR 30 YEARS.
MY DAUGHTER CAME FROM ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL AND SHE WAS SUPPOSED TO
WRITE A REPORT ON COLUMBUS.
THEY HAVE THREE CHOICES.
THEY SAID WAS COLUMBUS AN EVIL
MAN?
WAS HE JUST GREEDY?
OR WAS HE JUST A RUN-OF-THE-MILL
BAD GUY?
ALL BAD CHOICES.
SHE WROTE APRIL COLUMBUS REPORT
AND THE TEACHER SAID, WHAT WAS
YOUR SOURCE?
SHE SAID PRAGER YOU.
>> Greg: IT'S AN ONLINE THING
FROM DENNIS PRAGER.
PRAGER U.
YOU REALLY ARE AN ANGRY WHITE
MALE.
>> Tom: I TOLD HER TO WATCH
THE VIDEO AND SHE WROTE A GREAT
REPORT.
THIS IS WHAT THEY DO FROM A VERY
EARLY AGE SO YOU ALMOST CAN'T
BLAME THEM.
THEY HAVE BEEN GETTING THIS, WE
SAID THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
WHEN I WAS IN GRAMMAR SCHOOL
MANY YEARS AGO.
>> Greg: I REMEMBER THAT.
GOOD TIMES.
KAT.
IF YOU HAVE KIDS, WOULD YOU SEND
THEM TO COLLEGE?
IT SEEMS TO ME LIKE IT RUINS
THEM.
>> Kat: MY KIDS ARE ALL GOING
TO GO TO TRADE SCHOOL.
I WANT TO HAVE PLUMBER
DAUGHTERS.
>> Greg: PLUMBER DAUGHTERS.
>> Kat: THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE
A YOUTUBE SHOW.
IT'S ALL PLANNED OUT.
>> Greg: I WOULD WATCH AN
ALL-FEMALE PLUMBING COMPANY.
>> Kat: DON'T YOU TAKE MY
IDEA.
IT'S BEEN REALLY INTERESTING TO
SEE ALL OF THE SOCIAL JUSTICE
TYPES TRYING TO MAKE ALL OF
THESE DIFFERENT EXCUSES FOR WHY
THEY ARE REALLY PROTESTING IN
CUBA.
COVID, THE UNITED STATES.
THESE PROTESTERS ARE BEING QUITE
CLEAR THAT WHAT THEY ARE
PROTESTING, THE DICTATORSHIP
THEY ARE LIVING UNDER.
THESE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE WHO
SAY IF A PERSON OF COLOR CALLS
YOU RACIST AND YOU'RE WHITE, YOU
HAVE TO AGREE.
OR ELSE YOU ARE A DOUBLE RACIST
BECAUSE YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND.
THEY ARE TRYING TO EXPLAIN
COMMUNISM TO THEM, THE PEOPLE
LIVING UNDER IT AND PROTESTING
IT.
IT'S ALMOST AS IF IT'S A LITTLE
HYPOCRITICAL.
>> Greg: I WOULD SAY IT'S A
LOT HYPOCRITICAL.
>> Kat: I WOULD AGREE.
>> Greg: YOU'RE BEING
SARCASTIC.
YOU KNOW, I STILL GO BACK TO THE
SIDE THAT PEOPLE WANT TO BE
ACCEPTED BY THEIR PEER GROUPS.
RIGHT NOW TO BE ACCEPTED BY YOUR
PEER GROUP COMING HAVE TO BE
ANTI-PATRIOTIC WHICH MEANS THE
TRUE REBELS IN OUR SOCIETY ARE
THE ONES WHO ARE PATRIOTIC.
>> Tom: IT DOES!
RIGHT, PEOPLE!
>> Greg: WAY TO GET A